the road to shure
now hosts a sad parade
a procession of the dispossessed from
western t
grey seeking shelter in an overcrowded
city
more than 30 000 have made this journey
in the past 10 days
how do you feel
they say they've been forced to flee by
troops from neighboring eritrea
as well as militia from the region of
amhara to the south
and the men with guns act like they
meant to stay
the ethiopian government spent five
months denying the existence of eritrean
troops
and tanks and armored vehicles into grey
although they've dropped that pretence
and they looked like a force of
occupation to us a fearsome tool in the
fight
against the region's former leaders the
tplf
we stopped to talk to some villagers
along the way
how many eritrean soldiers are there i
asked
lots she whispered and do the villagers
have to be careful what they say
the eritrean army stands accused of
serious human rights abuses
including the destruction of refugee
camps in hitsa
and this one in shemelba
11 500 sought shelter here
from the eritrean regime
but it was subjected to a terrifying
assault
our team the first to document the
destruction
buildings were burnt health facilities
ransacked
medicine and supplies carted away
the attack on this refugee camp and the
one at hitsa by the eritrean army
may represent the single worst atrocity
in this vicious campaign there are still
thousands of people unaccounted for
we understand the camp at shimelba was
targeted on november 19th
amid heavy fighting with the opposition
tplf
we spoke to a man who said he witnessed
the attack
what happened to the people who were
[Music]
here
was attacked and partially destroyed in
mid-november
according to one camp resident refugees
were held for months
without food and clean water
[Music]
sammy who fled eritrea in 2019
told us camp residents were marched back
there in january
[Music]
he says he managed to escape in a border
town on the ethiopian side
but aid workers told us thousands of
refugees
have been forced to return to eritrea
in the city of shiree hundreds of
thousands
are camping in schools and sharing
stories of great personal suffering
and the sense of anguish here may be the
only thing
they have left john sparks sky news
into gray